welcome to atmosphere digital rethinking
security in the cloud I'm Erin
Feigenbaum director of security for
Google Apps we have this great panel
here of experts through all across
Google to talk about security
information security has become such a
hot topic with the increase in
cybercrime the trends in privacy the
changes in regulations it's something
that businesses can't ignore
enterprise's all over the world are
concerned about security and to have a
great conversation about information
security we've brought in four different
experts from all across Google each a
subject matter expert in security in
their own specific domain to my far left
here I have Tim Willis from our chrome
security team next up is Adrian Ludwig
Adrian is responsible for Android
security to my far right is Stefan
Samadhi Stefan is a product manager and
our security and privacy engineering
team to my immediate right is Suzanne
Frey she's the director of security
privacy and Trust for Google Apps
engineering the move of businesses the
cloud computing has really increased
their companies see the benefits of
lower cost but also the ability to
innovate faster for users to collaborate
but one of the big areas of hesitation
is security right companies are not
comfortable putting their own data into
the cloud how would you respond to
somebody that had that concern I think
we're seeing a real sea change right now
with respect to people understanding
that the cloud is more secure than on
any on-premise solution if you just
think about it mathematically you've got
all these different on-premise solutions
and individual teams trying to do the
right thing and with any cloud provider
you have the locus of the best talent
the best expertise centered on making
your solution secure in your data secure
if you take a look at our customer base
we have some of the world's largest
banks we have some of the most stringent
government customers were FedRAMP
certified here in the US and the fact
that we can solve for security for all
of those customers is a great testimony
to our capabilities but in addition we
solve for something special in talking
to our customers it's our
to innovate and to bring new ideas to
bear it help enable them to be
competitive productive and truly novel
and focus on the things that matter to
them that's part of our really special
secret sauce right and I often say to
people at Google security comes in two
forms it's both traditional
cybersecurity but it's also security
against technological stagnation that's
interesting so we don't usually think of
that second one very often we tend to
think of the data security that that's
great from a cloud perspective how does
that change in in the Android or mobile
world I like the observation about being
too focused on security to the exclusion
of innovation I hadn't seen that phrase
that way but I think one of the changes
that we've seen in the mobile space over
the last few years is companies have
focused first and foremost on innovation
Android being a great example of that
but we've tied it to a security model
that is how people actually consume
applications and services right so we
thought about the web and the sandboxing
model that was used on the web and we
incorporated that in the way we built
applications sandboxing I think a
consequence of that is cloud services
are becoming more and more important
most applications that are built for
Android that are built for mobile
regardless of your certain mobile
platform are really cloud based so I
think those two were tied together
because both of them are thinking about
innovation first and foremost and the
security sort of unlocked that
innovation so it seems like cloud is
actually a mobile as a reason for
companies to move to those environments
is there stuff that Google's doing that
others really can't I think it's
important to think of the context in
which we're talking in here so we have a
complex set of systems that we're
dealing with today they get more and
more complex over time we also have
adversaries with increasing levels of
sophistication so you've got that on one
side and on the other side we've got IT
managers having to defend their networks
the problem with defense is you need to
defend everything incredibly well
attackers only need to find one hole in
two
so I think that's where an advantage of
moon to the cloud is that you have
dedicated teams with robust experience
I mean Stephan and I were talking about
this earlier that some of the people who
won't work with wrote my textbooks in
university and it's one of those things
that you know I get to work with these
experts and that's all they do
they focus on security and that's one of
the huge benefits in my point of view
meaning to the cloud that's great well
we're protecting data while it's at
Google but we have to do a lot of stuff
to make sure the data safe when it's not
at Google right Safe Browsing would be a
good example of something that we can do
at very very large scale where we
actually believe that the right approach
is make the entire Internet safer so we
build systems that hunt around and find
malware and find phishing and then we go
and report this and so an individual
consumer can benefit from this because
their web browser will let them know in
a cloud environment enterprises can take
advantage of this data as well and keep
themselves protected and we take this
approach through a number of different
area certificate transparency being
another example where we're taking a
look at the Internet as a whole and
finding ways to keep it safe at scale so
obviously in working with various
experts and you guys are all experts in
your field right this encouraged us to
innovate and come up with lots of
security innovation some of those really
actually go beyond and change security
really move the needle from what users
are used to maybe you can all give me
one of those examples that we've done
I'd like to talk a bit about security
G's security keys have are you these
keys are fabulous you know for the
longest time you know we have been
talking about sort of two-factor
authentication is is critically
important for most of organizations to
implement and many customers use you
know Google Authenticator and other apps
like that to generate a one-time
passcode those are great they're
certainly better than nothing right
however a hardware based security key
such as these just quantum leaps ahead
in terms of you know they're not
hackable
and they really do protect our customers
from phishing in a way that you know
basically the the one-time passwords do
not so I think that's an interesting
point Suzanne especially talking about
you know they're not so glamorous side
of the things that we do one of those
things is encryption for me like it may
not seem incredibly innovative but we're
working really hard to make sure that
all of our traffic is encrypted at rest
and a transit and one example where
we're being open with that is our https
transparency report now you can go to
that site and you can see our progress
towards our goal of 100% encryption in
transit through all of our products
again another example would be working
with TLS 1.3 that's the next generation
of transport layer security now it may
not sound glamorous but we're not only
helping to implement that we're helping
author the next version so that shows
that we're in the mix and we kind of
know what technologies are around the
corner' a practical application of that
would be progressive web apps so these
are low friction web applications which
are designed to help increase engagement
and have an app like experience for
customers and businesses we've seen
studies how that increases engagement
and it's fantastic it's easy across the
board why am I talking about it well TLS
is actually a hard requirement for those
apps so it's one of these things where
not only are we innovating we're making
sure that security is baked in from the
get-go and I think that's one huge
advantage of Google there's a couple
elements about that that are interesting
one of them is it's not so much that the
security itself is innovative it's about
using an innovative product to make
security available one of the things
that we did early on with Android is we
thought about the platform stack rank
okay you need to have verified booed and
you need to have encryption you need to
have sandboxing those are all sort of I
think at this point almost commodities
for operating system but one of the
things that Google brought to bear was
security services right it's going to be
a cloud connected device and we're gonna
make all of those services available by
default on all the devices and so we
started thinking about how do you bind
services into the operating system
itself so we added things like safety
net and verify apps where there are
effectively hooks in the operating
system where we can make sure that we're
adding security sort of dynamically over
time so we can innovate in security even
more quickly than we can innovate
in the operating system itself does
anybody know that that's happening not
really but that's okay because they're
safer and they're happier as a result of
it so we sort of the same way that you
guys are doing with TLS and progressive
Web Apps binding those two things
together just kind of transparently and
in the background and there are two ends
of that spectrum
there's also transparency I'm Tim you
were already talking about the https
transparency report but we've been doing
transparency and we've been shining
light on ourselves for many many years a
couple of years back we did the safer
email transparency report where we were
looking at first of all is there
anything that we're doing that we could
do better and then having looked at that
what is the rest of the world doing and
it's actually moved the needle forward
we are now on a position to say yes as a
result of shining the light and
illuminating the greater situation on
the Internet
more people are using encryption for
their email it happens across all of our
transparency reports where first we look
at ourselves to see if we're doing the
best job that we possibly can and very
often then we cast our gaze more widely
into the outside world to see what else
is out there and if we can help people
improve things it transparent is
actually a really big part of moving to
the cloud I mean specially we see that a
lot with our enterprise customers right
I mean absolutely if you think about it
like anything if you don't know enough
or have sufficient information how in
the world can you make a decision right
and how can you how can you run your
business and I do think that
transparency has been one of the biggest
blockers to adoption across all cloud
products we've been investing in
multiple areas to ensure that
transparency is is front and center to
what we do we engage third-party
auditors right to help ensure and and
provide certifications against certain
standards like ISO 27000 17 and 18 our
FedRAMP process is also disclosed to the
government and and leveraged you know
uniquely in terms of making sure that
across our company we are aware of owner
abilities and and addressing them
quickly and I think just in general
providing information to the end-user
about whether or not you know their
employees have had a password violation
or I've had some suspicious activity or
giving them greater reporting detail you
know I'm the first to say that we've
still have some work to do with the
reporting front and I think everything
cloud provider does but we're working
really hard to improve the degree that
you know an administrator understands
everything that's happening within their
company and can take appropriate action
so along what you guys all talk about
whether it's transparency for our
enterprise customers or for all users or
some of the innovation in Android we
really wouldn't have expected years ago
I at least wouldn't have predicted that
you guys are all experts and very deep
in your field what would be your
security vision what's gonna change
what's gonna make our lives easier for
our users I think a lot of the security
as we've talked about before needs to
stay invisible and in some cases it's
gonna be a little bit counterintuitive
so a couple of months back we released a
product called onhub which is a home
networking router and one of the things
that it's particularly counterintuitive
about it but which is adding a lot more
security as the fact it's cloud managed
so all the technology that we devise to
protect our users accounts like Suzanne
was talking about with the security key
all of that benefits the user because
the Google account is the way the user
starts to manage their device at home so
as we connect all the various pieces of
our security puzzle they all work
together and suddenly have a device at
home which is actually cloud managed and
cloud secured which is not the way it
was even a few years ago there's a
distinct security benefit now I'd like
to talk a little bit about the elephant
in the room with respect to security
which is this dynamic tension between
access to data and keeping it secure I'm
one of the very hard things for most
enterprises is to say listen someone
else is going to be the governor of our
data our steward of our data perhaps I
should say and what is that company
gonna do with our data and I reference
you know audit reports and
certifications that we commit to every
year however machine learning is one of
the most exciting things that's
happening in the field of computer
science today and machine learning
requires training data to perform and
obviously with customer sharing data
with us we could just take that data and
go nuts which would be irresponsible of
Google and you know would really kill
our vision overall but I do think
solving that problem and putting our
customers in control of what data we can
use to enhance the way that they work to
improve productivity to reduce the costs
and to understand how competitive they
are in a global landscape for a given
industry that's super exciting stuff so
I think finding you know
gentle balance between making sure the
customers can maintain absolute control
over who sees their data when and uses
it for what it's one of the most
exciting problems we had to solve
because it's going to bring tremendous
advances to mankind well I feel like I'm
the guys going to talk about the boring
thing I think it's really exciting that
more and more companies are moving like
I think more deeply into the cloud I
mean for some background I before I
joined Google I was a sysadmin and an IT
manager until I caught the security bug
pun intended and ended up joining an
incident response team so a lot of what
I was doing was rolling out to companies
and departments who had been hacked and
helping them clean up their networks
helping them you know rebuild up their
defenses and kicking the miscreants out
and it's one of these things where as we
mentioned earlier it's just going to get
more and more sophisticated and it's
harder that moving to the cloud actually
buys you the Google security team in a
sense like it gives you the protection
that we're offering it lets you not have
to worry about that and one of the great
advantages of that is as an IT manager
you know I don't have to worry about
that I can I can sleep a little bit
better at not knowing that you know
Google's got my back when it comes to
security yeah I mean I think it's been
interesting talking with folks and
getting a little bit different
perspective I mean even in the last
minute or two we've heard discussion
about sort of hardware security and we
talked about machine learning and
pulling in data from different places
Google every conversation you learn a
little bit something new and I think
that's one of the key things that the
security industry is going through right
now we're beginning to a point where
there's enough maturation in all of our
products where there's enough data
that's being pulled in enough ability to
analyze that data where we can actually
start to make good decisions right for
generations really from a technology
standpoint we've been relying on
assumptions about what good security
looked like you know which things you
need to be worried about what risk is
likely to hit you but now that people
are moving into the cloud now that we
have operating systems like Android
we're trying to deploy security
solutions across the entire ecosystem we
get a lot of data we can analyze that
and we can start to make a really good
decision so I think that's the thing
that I'm most excited about over the
next few years is we're going to get to
the point where as professionals we can
actually
understand risk and make really good
risk based decisions which isn't
something we've been able to do in the
past it's not something is possible if
you're not in the cloud if you're not on
mobile so that's what I'm really excited
about the one thing that's really in
common with everything everybody said is
having a large security team that's
capable and has the expertise to really
ingest all that to be able to do the
things for you on the cloud or to use
all that data that now we have to make
products more and more secure or to
develop that machine learning so
hopefully this was a good insight for
everybody to hear what some of our
security leaders at Google are thinking
about what they're working on and what
they're working on in the future so
thank everybody for for taking the time
and listening in to us Thanks